a racer became a star an ex-girlfriend
inspired a character and the show all
started as a series of commercials as
the show had sent to its third season
only true fans will know these facts
about Ted lasso the inspiration for a TV
show can come from almost anywhere Ted
lasso is one of the few times in
television history that a full-length
show was born out of a series of
commercials in 2013 around the time that
he was leaving Saturday Night Live after
eight years Jason Sudeikis entertained
an offer from NBC Sports to appear in
spots to promote his broadcast of
English Premier League soccer why
Sudeikis soccer from another nation was
perceived as a Hard Sell and a distant
concept to American sports fans so NBC
needed a familiar funny face to make the
introduction to take his sold
Entertainment Weekly they had like four
or five ideas and one of them was an
American coach coaching soccer in London
he added that the character the ad
writers had initially devised was based
on a character who played in some SNL
sketches however sudakis was
uninterested in portraying that kind of
car anymore I just saw something a
little bit different and that is what
ended up becoming Ted lasso like a nice
guy like you know kind heart you know
someone that listens someone will push
you initially the character of Ted lasso
is straightforward an overly nice guy
quick with a joke or compliment he's a
real-life Ned Flanders
evening neighbor low on funds again but
as the first season of Ted lasso
progresses audiences learn that Ted's
got a lot more going on than just that
Jason sudeik is that the piece several
influences together to get the
characterization just right he told her
later I just felt like it'd be nice to
place someone kind as a little bit of a
challenge to myself it was an exercise
in trying to prove to myself that it's
possible to be a good person and still
be interesting and parts of the Ted
lasso look greatly informal Sudeikis and
habits there are my joke has been that
Audrey Hepburn used to say that she
really would find a character through
the Wardrobe through some Givenchy
outfit and me it's facial hair and the
aviators and the visor on a broader
level sudakis a comic actor playing a
more serious part than he usually does
took cues from the dramatic parts of
Robin Williams who took a similar career
trajectory according to variety Williams
played a lot of teachers and mentors who
a sudakers put it see more in you than
you can see in yourself and bring a
whole lot of that optimism counter to
Ted lassozark as an outsider finding his
way in English professional soccer
there's a character of Roy Kent a former
superstar now pastors Prime who doesn't
have too many seasons left in him he's a
Stern guy who's not fond of showing his
emotions and active Brett Goldstein
plays a character with nuance and
subtlety Goldstein is a filmmaker but
he's also a performer with an extensive
list of British TV and film credits
however he wasn't on producer's radar to
play Roy instead he was initially hired
as a member of the writing staff having
worked with co-creator Bill Lawrence
years earlier on a TV pilot but
Goldstein helped Lawrence sudakis and
the other writers in season 1 when he
realized he wanted to do something more
in the series as Goldstein told vulture
I just started to think I could play Roy
I really get it I really get this part
but I also knew it was not the sort of
part I would usually play he was also
afraid to ask if he could read for it
because he didn't want to embarrass
himself or anyone else so on the eve of
the final day of writing sessions he
taped himself doing five scenes as Roy
then emailed them to Lawrence he said
the audition was good Ted lasso writer
Greg dolstein landed the part of Roy
Ken's but the role was sort of
originated by another Ted lasso writer
co-creator Brendan hunt who also acts on
the show is coach beard hunts developed
his comedy chops in the early 2000s as
part of the comedy troupe boom Chicago
which staged lots of shows in Europe in
that Collective he started working
closely with Joe Kelly and Jason
Sudeikis and all three are credited with
bringing Ted lasso to television in 2003
boom Chicago's toyin show explored some
elements that would form the foundation
of the Ted lasso TV series mon sketch
concerned an American trying to
understand the unique culture
surrounding Amsterdam's Ajax soccer
Squad another piece was a spotlight
moment for hunt for impersonated and
Lampoon's the acid tongued Irish soccer
star Roy Keane who at the time played
for England's dominant Manchester United
Squad a bitter real-life soccer star
named Roy Keane is just a short jump to
a bitter fictional soccer star named Roy
Kent the premise of Ted lasso was simple
but compelling an American football
coach has hired to run an English
football team meaning soccer he
initially knows very little about the
game because for him like most Americans
soccer isn't a major sport amusingly the
American actor who plays Ted lasso Jason
Sudeikis found himself in a similar
situation when the show began production
sudakis told Entertainment Weekly that
at the start he knew very little about
soccer and that he hadn't played the
game since he was 10. most of his
knowledge came from his more advanced
co-creator and co-star Brendan hunt it
also helped that he and Hunter have been
playing EA Sports FIFA soccer video
games together for 20 years when Ted
lasso ramped up sudakis hunts and some
other shows other writers and cast
members started playing a few nights a
week with a customized team in the game
as on the show sudakis and his group
plays as AFC Richmond adding that we
designed the players to look like our
guys as much as possible Ted lasso is a
show about an American set in Great
Britain but behind the scenes is an
American production with a theme song
and score by a British musician Marcus
Mumford frontman of the very popular
band Mumford and Sons Landing Mumford
was relatively easy as he's good friends
with Ted lasso star and co-creator Jason
Sudeikis they met when Mumford and Sons
played Saturday Night Live during
sudakus's tenure and then the comedian
appeared in the band's video for
Hopeless Wanderer but that's not the
only fascinating tidbit about the
soundtrack probably the most memorable
musical moment on Ted lasso occurs in
for the children when a high-profile
celebrity musician can't be secured to
perform at the 10th Annual benefit for
underprivileged children Ted brings in a
street musician who dazzles the crowd
with her singing and guitar work that
Busker is Cam call a real street
musician who can be found performing on
the Streets of London Ted lasso is a
charming and generous guy and that
manifests in his interactions with his
boss Rebecca he offers the initially
commercial Rebecca daily deliveries of
shortbread cookies so delicious that
they help endear him to his new bus
while ambitious home Bakers have
painstakingly studied the very brief
scenes of Ted in the kitchen to figure
out as many ingredients and techniques
as possible the ones used in shooting
aren't anything to obsess over Hannah
waddingham who plays Rebecca is the one
person in the Ted lasso cast who gets to
eat those biscuits and she isn't a fan
she told vulture they were chunky
shortbreads that sucked all of the
saliva out of my face when I was trying
to act and talk at the same time they
weren't inedible but they weren't like
Yum Yum Yum give me the biscuits Ted
lasso is about a man coaching a storied
if presently not very good soccer team
in the top level of the English Premier
League and in the show the team faces
such legendary real-life opponents as
Liverpool and Manchester City lasso's
squad however isn't actually real AFC
Richmond was invented for the series
however there are elements of real
reality to the team and even the
neighborhood of London it supposedly
represents while it doesn't feel the
Premier League soccer team in reality
Richmond is a real place the actual
Richmond is Richmond Park or rather the
crown estate of Richmond Park located in
the county of Surrey as for the Premier
League level soccer stadium where AFC
Richmond plays on Ted lasso it isn't in
Richmond Park a Show's forcing sequences
are produced at selhurst Park the home
turf of actual Team Crystal Palace FC
and as you've probably guessed from the
name the stadium can be found in
selhurst a suburb of London there's a
big difference between American and
British comedies American sitcoms
usually run indefinitely with Seasons
consisting of around 20 episodes British
sitcoms might run for only a few series
of a half dozen installments before the
creators call it a day Ted lasso is an
American show about British culture and
it's following the lead of short and
sweet predecessors like the UK version
of the office in fact it had its length
planned from the get-go said lasso was
designed to air for exactly three short
seasons and are has been hinted at in
the show itself in the season 1 finale
Ted tells owner Rebecca after the team
is relegated to a lower division until
spend the next year getting them back to
the Premier League and then the year
after that they'll win the championship
so far that's matched the season finales
the character of Keely Jones model AFC
Richmond PR consultant and Roy Kent's
love interest was encouraged in part by
a woman in sudakis's life and evolved
after the casting of Juno Temple
according to people sudakis met English
model and actor Keeley Hazel on the set
of Horrible Bosses 2 in 2014. they
briefly dated in 2021 after season one
of Ted lasso aired in which Hazel
appeared in three episodes as Bex the
partner of old AFC Richmond owner Rupert
Manion Temple told Entertainment Tonight
she is a friend of Jason that inspired
some of keeley's character she was an
inspiration for the part judaicius asked
temple with whom he shares an agent to
play Keeley as originally conceived the
Keeley character wasn't as outwardly
comical as other tedlasu characters but
that changed after the read through of
the pilot a script Goldstein told the
independent Not only was she funny but
us the writers were like oh she's
funnier than we've written the character
that changed the most in the writing was
Keely because of Juno in the season one
finale Ted excitedly exits Rebecca's
office energize about how he can solve a
problem as he runs out he jumps up and
clicks his heels together knocking his
head on the top of the door frame that
brief and chaotic sequence was one part
improv comedy and one part in Julius
accident sudakis explained on the Drew
Barrymore show in 2021 I really hit my
head there that was a complete accident
I jumped up and then I boom cracked my
head I I roll like I do I stand up I
think I'm fine Sudeikis then exited the
scene of scripted and noticed first a
trickle of blood coming from his head
and then a rapid flow of the stuff onset
Medics reacted quickly using a liquid
adhesive to seal the sizable wound so he
could keep working Ted lasso is one of a
handful of television series to win
multiple Emmy Awards for outstanding
comedy series well cheers took home the
prize for times there's another Ted
lasso connection George Wendt was part
of cheers for 11 years playing Barfly
Norm Peterson and the actor is the
maternal Uncle of Jason Sudeikis as such
that tedlass of universe is lace with
shout outs of both its creator and
Star's uncle and his popular sitcom in
one scene Roy Kent patronizes a kebab
shop and his photo Graces the wall
flanked by autographed images of Marcus
Mumford of Mumford and Sons and went
elsewhere in season 2 a workplace
romance develops between Richmond AFC
had Rebecca and player Sam mirroring the
Rebecca and some relationship in cheers
and in one episode this happens
hmm
cheers
backboard
why does dead say this in the late 1980s
Night Court followed cheers on NBC's
Thursday night's schedule
and Richardson almost always plays a
nice and goofy guy on TV notably in Veep
and detroitus Richardson played against
type when he showed up near the end of
season 2 of Ted lasso as Edwin afuko a
billionaire from Ghana who will stop at
nothing to lure away AFC Richmond star
Sam obisanya for his own soccer team
Richardson has lots of connections to
the Ted lasso creative team he
co-created detroiters with Joe Kelly one
of the developers of Ted lasso while
sedakius also served as a producer and
guest starred in a couple of episodes of
The Comedy Central Series in 2017.
Richardson's work on Ted lasso brings a
cameo favor full circle Richardson's
appearance of the villain was so crucial
to the plot of Ted lasso season 2 that
it was all kept Under Wraps the actor
revealed in an interview with Brad
Galley uh it was it was a huge secret
game I didn't want to like like uh give
him that away when he went to London to
film he couldn't tell his relatives who
lived there exactly while he was in town
or even that he was playing opposite a
character named Sam who he claims as his
namesake
[Music]
thank you